the version of Donald Trump that I call Downar.
Trump showed up yesterday in the Rose Garden
to sign an executive order about police departments
directing police departments to stop using
chokeholds.
And Donald Trump did look very, very unwell.
And he said things that made no sense whatsoever.
So this, again, raised questions about whether
Donald Trump is suffering the side effects
of some illness, side effects of medication,
cognitive decline, something else that we
can't seem to put a finger on.
We discussed yesterday on the bonus show extensively
the question of police using chokeholds and
the reality that the priority should be rather
than a list of tactics that police can and
can't use.
The focus should be on training officers to
de-escalate situations so that chokeholds
aren't even in the picture.
But we talked about that yesterday.
Right now, I want to focus on the absolute
implosion of Donald Trump during this Rose
Garden statement.
Here is Donald Trump saying that we have developed
a vaccine for AIDS.
Now, that's not true.
We have not developed a vaccine for AIDS and
Trump, when he says it gets that look on his
face where he seems to understand that he
said something wrong.
But he almost is lost and doesn't know what
he said.
It was like that time where he did the oranges
of the investigation thing and he kind of
tries to back it up and mumbles a few things.
Take a look at this.
They have come up with things and they've
come up with many other cures and therapeutics
over the years.
These are the people, the best, the smartest,
the most brilliant anywhere.
And they've come up with the AIDS vaccine
they've come up with or the AIDS.
And as you know, there's various things and
now various companies are involved.
But the therapeutic for AIDS.
AIDS was a death sentence.
And now people live a life with a pill.
It's an incredible thing.
The Ebola vaccine.
So that same confusion happened when Trump
repeatedly said he wanted to find out the
oranges, the citrus fruit of an investigation.
He said it twice and he had a look where he
knew he was saying something that didn't make
sense.
But he almost couldn't even pass it in his
own mind.
It didn't get any better during the same event.
Donald Trump seemed to lose his train of thought.
This is another pattern we've seen where he
forgets what he's talking about.
He will just look at someone and say, right.
You know what I'm talking about, don't you?
We've seen this before.
This time he looks into the audience and he
says right to him.
We're going to pursue things very strongly.
You can tell if you're watching that Trump
doesn't seem lucid when you look at his face
right when this is happening.
Take a look.
And I gave a commitment to all of those families
today with Senator Tim Scott, Attorney General
Bill Barr.
We are going to pursue what we said.
We will be pursuing it and we will be pursuing
it strongly.
Tim.
Mike Pence, wacky stuff at another moment.
Donald Trump was talking about putting down
the protesters by using the National Guard.
And, of course, putting down is certainly
not the most humane language to use.
Trump bragging about how strongly the protesters
were handled at your federal government is
ready, willing and able to help, as we did
in Minneapolis after he got out of control
for four days.
He sent in representatives commonly known
as the National Guard, and it was all put
down very quickly.
We're willing to help.
We're willing to help in Seattle.
Anywhere you want.
So when there are protests against police
brutality and your response is to brag about
how much force you directed to be used against
the protesters, something is not quite getting
through.
Then Donald Trump absolutely bizarrely interjecting
a complete non sequitur about school choice
being the civil rights issue of our time.
Take a look at this.
We're fighting for school choice, which really
is the civil rights of all time in this country.
Frankly, school choice is the civil rights
statement of the year.
So understand that when Republicans talk about
school choice, what they really mean is defund
public schools, weaken public schools, often
with voucher programs which go to charter
schools, which then continues the vicious
cycle of worsening public schools because
you've just pulled money from them.
This is a favorite of Republicans say public
education is bad.
Of course, it's underfunded.
Use that to justify taking more money out
of public education, which makes it worse.
So that then they can again justify.
Look at how bad public education is.
We've got to do more charter schools and private
schools.
It's an old trope from Republicans.
And then lastly here, another one of these
moments where Donald Trump lists different
races and ethnicities and incorrectly claims
that almost everybody had a high paying job
before the Corona virus hit.
That's for almost every group, including black,
Hispanic, Asian women, young people, old people,
young people without a high school diploma.
Every group, everybody was thrilled.
Everybody had.
Just about high paying jobs.
Our country was never in a better position
and we were planning on massive growth.
It was happening.
It was already there.
So one of the things we've seen in terms of
job creation before Corona coronavirus hit
was that while the jobs numbers were good
and I have no problem admitting that a lot
of the jobs being created where we're what
we call B.S. jobs, not medium or high wage
jobs, but low wage jobs or sometimes jobs
that aren't even really jobs.
They're contractor positions.
And this is a common deception that we are
hearing from the right.
So there it is, a combination of Donald Trump
looking and sounding confused, making verifiably
false claims.
And the mood in the audience, a combination
of quiet confusion, horror, but also blind
loyalty.
The people that see this and at least tell
themselves that everything is completely fine.
So we're going to be following up on this
on our Instagram page.
If you're not following the show on Instagram,
please do at David Pakman show.
And in fact, this is getting so bad that it
has gone on to Fox News, FOX News talking
about the Trump health situation.
A Republican group now targeting Trump around
health concerns.
So this is important that it is broken past
just certain areas.
And even elements of the right are now talking
about Trump's health and being put in a position
to have to defend it.
We'll get to that after the interview.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot.com.